X
NEWS PRIMETIME."
♪
>> Pete: I'M YOUR HOST PETE
HEGSETH TONIGHT AND FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE WEEK.
AND ONCE AGAIN, WE TRAIN OUR
EYES ON TEXAS BECAUSE FOR ALL
INTENTS AND PURPOSES IT HAS
BECOME TEXAS VS. THE WORLD.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO WOEFULLY FAIL TO
SECURE OUR SOUTHERN BORDER AND
OF COURSE LIE ABOUT IT THE WHITE
HOUSE IS PROVING THAT ITS AWOL
AND HAS NO DESIRE TO QUELL THIS
ESCALATING CRISIS.
>> WE ARE CONTINUING TO EDGES
PELL PEOPLE COMING FROM A RANGE
OF COUNTRIES AS WE ARE
CONTINUING TO APPLY TITLE 42.
BECAUSE THERE'S A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC THAT IS ONGOING.
>> Pete: THAT WAS ONE HECK OF A
PRESS CONFERENCE TODAY.
THE ONLY THING THEY CAN POINT TO
IS A TRUMP ERA RULE THAT THEY
HATE AND THEY USE AS A TALKING
POINT TO PRETEND TO DEPORT SOME
PEOPLE.
JUST MORE LIES COMING FROM AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT IS FULL OF
THEM.
AND TODAY WE LEARN THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS RELEASED
THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS OF
BIDENVILLE.
SINCE THEIR ONLY GOAL IS TO
CLEAR OUT OF THE CAMP AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE.
YOU GOT TO MAKE THE PICTURES GO
AWAY.
THAT'S THE ONLY GOAL.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THOSE
SO-CALLED DEPORTATIONS, THEY ARE
ONLY WORRIED ABOUT SINGLE ADULT
MALES, IT SEEMS, WITH FAMILY
UNITS AND PREGNANT WOMEN BEING
ALLOWED TO STAY.
MEANING MORE ANCHOR BABIES AND
MORE ILLEGALS.
ACCORDING TO BORDER PATROL
CHIEF, BRANDON JUDD.
OVER 600,000 OF THE ILLEGAL
BORDER CROSS ARERS HAVE RELEASE
NOT U.S. UNDER CATCH AND RELEASE
SINCE BIDEN TOOK OFFICE 8 MONTHS
AGO.
600,000.
AND NOW REPORTS SHOW ILLEGALS
POPPING UP IN STATES AS FAR AS
AWAY AS FLORIDA, NEW YORK,
MARYLAND, AND MANY MORE, WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT.
IN A FEW MOMENTS, WE ARE GOING
TO TALK TO ONE EYEWITNESS ON THE
GROUND WHO HAS A FIRSTHAND
ACCOUNT OF A PREGNANT WOMAN FROM
THE BIDENVILLE BRING IN DEL RIO
BEING FLOWN TO FLORIDA IN ORDER
TO GIVE BIRTH TO A NEW ANCHOR
BABY SON.
AND IT'S NOT JUST PREGNANT WOMEN
WHO ARE ABOUT TO BIRTH THAT ARE
ALLOWED TO STAY.
AS FOX NEWS BILL MELUGIN
REPORTS, ALL A WOMAN HAS TO DO
IS CLAIM SHE IS PREGNANT AND SHE
WILL BE RELEASED.
THEY ARE ASKED TO PLEASE REPORT,
PLEASE, PRETTY PLEASE, REPORT TO
IMMIGRATION WITHIN 60 DAYS.
ON THEIR OWNs.
SO IT'S STILL OPEN SEASON ON THE
U.S. BORDER AND IT LOOKS LIKE
ALMOST EVERYONE IS ALLOWED TO
STAY.
WHY THE SURGE IN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS THIS PAST YEAR?
WELL, BECAUSE BIDEN INVITED
THEM.
WHEN ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
>> I WOULD IN FACT MAKE SURE
THERE IS, WE IMMEDIATELY SURGE
TO THE BORDER ALL THOSE PEOPLE
SEEKING ASYLUM.
THEY DESERVE TO BE HEARD.
THAT'S WHO WE ARE.
WE ARE A NATION THAT SAYS IF YOU
WANT TO FLEE AND FLEEING
OPPRESSION, YOU SHOULD COME.
>> Pete: YOU SHOULD COME.
THAT'S THE ONLY MESSAGE THE
THIRD WORLD HEARD.
YOU SHOULD COME.
AND THE MESSAGE WAS RECEIVED
LOUD AND CLEAR BY THE HOARD OF
ILLEGALS LOOKING TO RUSH.
>> ALL THE GIVEN US 100 DAYS TO
GET TO THE U.S.
>> Pete: HERE'S THE THING THAT
100 DAYS HAS NEVER ENDED.
KIND OF LIKE TWO WEEKS TO SLOW
THE SPREAD.
SO FAR IT'S BEEN 245 VERY LONG
DAYS.
245 DAYS OF BIDEN WAVING THE
FLIGHT FLAG ON THE U.S. BORDER
AND ROLLING OUT THE WELCOME MAT
FOR ANYONE FROM ANYWHERE FOR
PRETTY MUCH ANY REASON.
HE KEEPS TELLING US THAT HE IS
GOING TO GET THE BORDER UNDER
CONTROL.
BUT HOW CAN HE KNOW IF IT'S
NEVER -- HOW CAN HE KNOW IF THE
BORDER IS UNDER CONTROL IF HE
HAS NEVER BEEN THERE TO SEE THE
REALITY FIRSTHAND?
>> HAS PRESIDENT BIDEN EVER BEEN
TO THE SOUTHERN BORDER?
>> IN HIS LIFE?
>> YES.
>> I WILL HAVE TO GET -- LOOK
BACK IN MY HISTORY BOOKS AND
CHECK THE TIMES HE HAS BEEN TO
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING ALL
MORNING AND WE CANNOT FIND ANY
RECORD OF HIM VISITING THE
BORDER AS PRESIDENT, VICE
PRESIDENT, SENATOR, OR EVEN AS A
CONCERNED CITIZEN.
WHY WOULD THAT BE?
>> I CAN CHECK AND SEE WHEN THE
LAST TIME OR WHEN HE MAY HAVE
SPENT.
>> Pete: IN HIS LIFE?
WE ARE STILL WAITING FOR THAT
ANSWER FROM THE WHITE HOUSE BY
THE WAY WHICH WE WILL BRING TO
YOU IF AND WHEN WE GET IT THE
GUY HAS BEEN IN GOVERNMENT
LONGER THAN I HAVE BEEN ALIVE
AND HE MAY HAVE NEVER BEEN TO
THE SOUTHERN BORDER?
NO PICTURES?
NO EVENTS?
NOTHING AT ALL?
I MEAN, HE HAS BEEN TO
AFGHANISTAN AND IRAQ DOZENS OF
TIMES.
MEXICO MANY TIMES.
BUT NEVER TO THE BORDER EVER?
MAYBE THE WHITE HOUSE WILL COME
UP WITH SOME OBSCURE FORMER
VISIT AS A WHOLE.
HE DOESN'T CARE.
HE NEVER HAS.
AND NOW HE IS A USEFUL TOOL FOR
THE OPEN BORDER LEFT TO
COMPLETELY CONTROL, YOU KNOW,
THAT BIG WHITE BUILDING HE
CURRENTLY WANDERS AROUND IN.
BIDEN HAS NO IDEA WHAT'S GOING
ON N TEXAS.
HE HAS HAD SOME STRONG OPINIONS
ON HAITI IN THE PAST.
>> IF HAITI GOD AWFUL THING TO
SAY IF HAITI JUST QUIETLY SUNK
INTO THE CARIBBEAN OR ROSE UP
300 FEET, IT WOULDN'T MATTER A
WHOLE LOT.
>> Pete: SOUNDS PRETTY RACIST TO
ME.
NOW HE SAYS HE IS GOING TO
DEPORT THEM BUT IS HE ACTUALLY
NOT.
NOW HE JUST EHE IS JUST A RACIST
AND A LIAR.
AND APPARENTLY HIS
ADMINISTRATION BORDER PAROLE.
GIVEN FAKE NEWS REPORTS.
THE WHIP, THE SMEARING THEIR
WORK.
>> PLEASE WATCH THE PHOTOS OF
HAITIANS GATHERING UNDER A
BRIDGE WITH FAMILIES AND
HORRIFIC VIDEO OF THE CBP VIDEO
ON HORSES USING BRUTAL AND
INAPPROPRIATE MEASURES AGAINST
INNOCENT PEOPLE.
>> Pete: HORRIFIC VIDEO THAT'S
BEEN DEBUNKED.
ONLY PEOPLE TAKING BRUTAL AND
INAPPROPRIATE MEASURES AGAINST
INNOCENT PEOPLE ARE THE MEXICAN
CARTEL WHO ARE TRAFFICKING THESE
PEOPLE FOR CASH.
BUT THE WHITE HOUSE NEFF
MENTIONS THAT BECAUSE BY FLYING
THESE ILLEGALLY TRAFFICKED
PEOPLE ACROSS THE COUNTRY, OUR
GOVERNMENT HAS BECOME AN
EXTENSION OF THE CARTEL
PIPELINE.
THE CARTELS GET THEM TO THE
BORDER.
JOE BIDEN HE TAKES IT FROM
THERE.
NOW, TODAY WE LEARN THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE IS DISCIPLINING THE
HORSE RIDING BORDER AGENT FOR
SIMPLY DOING THEIR JOB.
AS NEW REPORTS SHOW THOSE AGENTS
HAVE BEEN SHIFTED TO DESK DUTY
AMID AN INVESTIGATION.
THEY WILL PROBABLY BE PROCESSING
RELEASED ILLEGALS.
WELL DONE, JOE.
TRASHING THE ONLY PEOPLE
ACTUALLY DOING THEIR JOB.
WHO WOULD YOU LIKE IT CONTROL
THE BORDER?
OH, NOBODY?
YEAH,WE ALREADY KNOW THAT.
ONCE AGAIN, DON'T WORRY, AS VICE
PRESIDENT GIGGLES IS ON TOP OF
IT.
SHE IS ON HER WAY.
NOT TO TEXAS.
NO, NO, NO.
THAT WOULD MAKE TOO MUCH SENSE.
INSTEAD SHE IS HEADING TO NEW
YORK TO JOIN THE CREW ATVIEW
THIS WEEK.
SO TO RECAP.
BIDENVILLE RESIDENTS NOT BEING
DETORTED.
CARTELS RUNNING THE SHOW, JOE
BIDEN HELPING THEM.
BRAVE BORDER PATROL AGENTS ON
DESK DUTY.
ROOT CAUSE KAMALA AWOL IN TEXAS
VS. THE WORLD.
BECAUSE THE MESSAGE IS LOUD AND
CLEAR FROM THIS WHITE HOUSE T